this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week he's taking another look at the
weapons from Destiny 2 and specifically
some of the guns from its lightfall
expansion okay before I see this thing
in action I have a very nice view of it
it's it's the sort of Magnum revolver
Trope but it's a bit different as is
this which I think is probably the
closest
real gun to this hand Cannon let us know
what other games or guns you'd like to
see Jonathan break down and make sure to
subscribe for more of this kind of
content on the channel including Loadout
which takes an in-depth look at the most
iconic firearms in gaming right let's
take a look at the weapons from Destiny
2 lightfall
this is a pretty garish looking Auto
rifle of some sort the classic Sci-fi
thumb hole stock which well as I say
sci-fi can't seem to get away from
whether it's a phaser rifle or or
something that's shooting bullets which
this seems to be doing cases look a lot
like 7.62 by 39 but the the report is
definitely not that of an AK and we've
got some weird colored Tracer type
effects coming out it's almost like
energized kinetic rounds with some sort
of energy aspect to them and I haven't
figured out the weird crossbow piano
wire
time setup on top of the gun yet uh very
wacky design fairly extensive use of
some space age polymers or something as
far as Behavior goes it's pretty
conventional you know it could it could
probably be an M4 or something and if
this was not set in space
all right
right this is ringing a vague Bell in
terms of the the hand Cannon as a class
of weapon in this game it's huge this
thing the reload system I think is I've
seen I think I've seen before with a
sort of Speed Loader slash internal
cylinder that's replaced the the Yoke
that the cylinder comes out on is
immense which would make it very strong
but excessively heavy and forgive me if
I'm repeating myself based on this
generic type in in Destiny but the the
hammer is a bit like on a Nerf gun
pretty cool has to be said as a what
what you might do if somehow revolvers
are worth pursuing which I don't think
they would be with only only five or six
shots I don't care how advanced your
technology is I can't see it's ever
going back to revolvers as a mainstream
handgun I don't think that's very
controversial but I'm sure someone will
object
yeah
the first thing I noticed with this was
its unusual overall design it's it's a
very sci-fi aesthetic to this it's much
less conventional than say the revolver
that we've seen some gubbins hanging off
the front there that is some sort of
Energy System but we've got a Reload
into the magazine sorry into the into
the grip so but my overall impression is
is of a an energy weapon but it's
behaving like a sort of machine pistol
like a fully automatic pistol I could
see advanced technology making something
super compact High rate of fire more
useful in a future context like maybe
that stuff at the front of this gun was
some sort of recoil mitigation now
another thing I've picked up on this
thing pretty pretty immediately from the
side view was the early 2000s uh laser
device or what seems to be a laser
device on the side the shape of it the
way it's clipped onto the gun and the
only thing it's missing is a little
pressure switch lead coming off the back
of it or something it's it looks like
looks like the old laser aiming device
that you used to see on P90s so now I'm
Insight can't see this laser looking
thing doing any lasering blazing because
you've got your reticle on the screen at
all times anyway so it's kind of
academic but a bit curious overall shape
of the thing is that is unusual it does
almost look like it's the way it tapers
down at the back reminiscent of I don't
know the machine gun top cover there
might be some inspiration from real guns
going on there but it's it's a stretch
actually this does have a full length
pistol slide it's a very chunky pistol
frame effectively with a slide on top so
it's very reminiscent of real world
Firearms but it it's been taken Beyond
into the well into the realm of Science
Fiction
all right I think this gun is ticking a
lot of a lot of boxes for for sci-fi gun
for me in that it's well you can tell
it's a gun which is always a bonus but
it's not kind of adhering too closely to
present day Aesthetics or well I mean
technology wise who knows or I don't
know anyway exactly how this is supposed
to work but it has it has the the tropes
of feed device cocking handle automatic
fire a red dot type site or reflex type
site it's all recognizable FPS type
stuff but the Aesthetics and the
apparent function of it are nicely far
removed I think the optic itself is a
bit looks a bit exposed and maybe a bit
vulnerable but hey if Alloys are that
good then that frame is probably good
enough but it does it does unfortunately
remind me a bit of the spurious Optics
on the more recent World War II FPS
games
that's not it's not the the ball to the
designer I think it's just coincidence
but it reminds me of some of those not
quite existent or certainly not issued
Optics from those games there's not it's
not Destiny's fault that they look like
that it's actually an original design
foreign
this is not very sci-fi this looks like
something that could have existed in
fact if you've seen the crazy array of
Cold War era Soviet Firearms designs you
know some of those are wackier frankly
than what we have here on the face of it
this is um well that's gonna say it's a
somewhat conventional bullpup rifle but
then when I look at where the bolt
appears to be it's in the wrong place so
we've got a magazine at the back
contains your cartridges very short
action behind that but we know there are
ways to feed rounds with such a short
action that's less of a problem but
what's breaking my brain slightly is
that we seem to have an ak-esque bolt
and a semi AK top cover over the top of
it well forward so the chamber seems to
be very far forward but anyway
regardless of the technicalities the the
vibe is very much of a conventional
firearm firing ordinary ammunition
there's a huge paddle magazine release
that looks a bit problematic for
accidentally knocking out your magazine
it's a sort of thing that real world
designers have to think about and of
course video game designers do not
overall I like the I like the sort of
alternate or future Cold War escalate to
it it has AK design cues that trigger
guard is reminiscent as well pistol grip
maybe less so but the fact that it has
wood on it and green painted metal as
well it manages to look quite futuristic
but also retro at the same time
foreign
launcher pretty conventional this looks
like something that could exist but is
not directly based I don't believe on
any one launcher hence I have grabbed
Off the Wall here this this is the the
British Hilton
mprg multi-purpose Riot gun it's not a
not intended to launch rag grenades it's
a 37 mil
um right gun less lethal launcher but it
does have the same top brake system with
latch as this appears to have they'll
see that in the gameplay footage now the
the receiver the the grip frame bit of
this does not extend under the barrel as
much as it does on the game version and
this is a bit of an elephant in the room
as well however
the Hilton did allow you to pull that
off and that does give you something
that's not a Million Miles Away
from that albeit it has a more
traditional
Riot gun style aperture rear sight
rather than the fronts m79 style tangent
type site or ladder types I should say
that's fitted to a suspiciously
Picatinny looking rail on the top of
this thing but it does also have the
full grip which most British Riot guns
did not have this one did so that's what
I've gone with although this isn't
rifled and the video game model clearly
is and you do want rifling for a grenade
launcher because you need to be able to
land those tiny bombs where they need to
go
um
um what's what's interesting from a real
world parallel perspective here is the
bouncing the grenade off the ground and
into the people in front of you that's
not done with lethal purpose grenades
because you're going to well depending
on arming distances blow up on the
ground or more likely cause significant
damage to the round such that it won't
initiate however it was done
historically and controversially with
right gun projectiles baton rails it was
thought that by you'd be taking out some
energy from the projectile and
potentially not hurting the rioter but
in reality what would happen is you just
lose control over the accuracy and the
bouncing rubber baton or plastic bullet
would hit you somewhere less than ideal
like the face and course Serious injury
so that our tactics will change there's
a reason why they're now called Leslie
for weapons let's put it that way on a
lighter note it does make for some
interesting gameplay to be able to
bounce grenades off surfaces whether
that's off the ground as is done has
been done historically with launches and
then walls and things ceilings it's yeah
it really changes things up from the
usual sort of hit scans Affair To A
Bouncing projectile munition that needs
a bit of thought as to where it's going
and of course might cause you damage
when it goes off
okay before I see this thing in action I
have a very nice view of it it's it's
the sort of Magnum revolver Trope but
it's a bit different as is this which I
think is probably the closest real gun
to this hand Cannon so this is the door
revolver it's it's big it's a sizeable
caliber it's British George door was a
British designer it's opened up like a
cult and this this does have some some
cult look to it but to me it has the the
arguably more graceful lines of the door
of all that and especially around this
the shape of this trigger guard and of
the frame
it doesn't have the the hump here for
the web of the hand the the swell but
I'd be prepared to believe that someone
saw one of these at some point or it's
it could be sheer coincidence in which
case it's an even more impressive design
because they managed to come up with
something that looks like a real gun
thank you
foreign
Right In Action this thing's a bit
curious because the hammer is well if
it's moving it's not moving enough to
actually act like a hammer and also
unlike the real revolver there appears
to be no rotation of the cylinder now
that's fine with the hand cannons where
there's an internal cylinder that's
that's hidden that is rotating the major
difference between this real gun and
this virtual one is there's no pivot
point and there's no brake action to
load this this is percussion you would
have to cap each of these nipples on the
on the back of the gun with the hammer
cocked which is not ideal but anyway
and have loaded in here your powder and
your bullet
um our cartridge conversion you would
have to pop out this wedge there is a
wedge shown on this model so they were
if they weren't referring to this they
were referring to a cult you drive out
the wedge pop off the barrel assembly
and swap the cylinders you could in
theory do that and so this is a cylinder
swap gun but the cylinder is not turning
another very sci-fi design I keep saying
that on this on this episode but Bear's
repeating that this has been consciously
designed to look futuristic having said
that if you squint there are F2000 Vibes
to this I think I might be reading into
it but the separation of the the lines
sort of panel lines on top are a little
bit reminiscence the general curvy
tactical tuner shape and what looks
almost like or reminds my of my brain at
least of the flip up breech lid that's
on the F2000 but it's not a ballpark
yeah it's not necessarily going to
remind you of an F2000 but it it did me
one design feature that is something we
see on real guns but not tremendously
practical for what's essentially an
assault rifle like this is the big
support rib for the magazine we see
designs that have that you have it on
weapons that fire big or use big chunky
feed devices like the AA-12 because it
needs that that structural Port
something like an assault rifle does not
need that just shut the magazine in and
it's held in by the caption by the shape
of the magazine well and it's that's
fine so you don't need the extra
protrusion coming off the bottom of the
gun making it taller from the magazine
isn't fitted you don't have to in the
middle of a firefight make sure it
guides properly into the channel works
well with the aesthetic it sort of
balances out a little bit the big chunky
gum bit from the slightly Slimmer
magazine bit it's more it Blends it more
in more so I see why they've done it
artistically but it's something that
stuck out for me
a pump action shotgun in space this
happens a lot we cannot get away from
perhaps we shouldn't get away from
um the good old-fashioned 12 gauge pump
it's just everywhere they existed in the
old west and some games include them in
in their old west setting you see them
in the first world war second world war
Vietnam present day the future there's
just something very cool about the old
pump action especially if you can use
that sir rate of fire to offset a more
powerful shotgun blast and so really
it's an aesthetic sort of skin for a
Remington 870 or something to be fair is
aesthetically well you know it's not
Winchester 1897 or Remington 870 or
something in space it is its own design
at the end of the day it's a pump action
shotgun
foreign
a very Destiny name for this thing and
deterministic Chaos I suspect there's
some law behind that way I know there's
some law behind that because we have a
uh quote from a Schrodinger there it
certainly does not look like a
conventional gun other than having a
belt of some sort of energy ammunition
and a distinct belt box drum type thing
it's looking a little bit less than
ergonomic at the rear there something
unusual going on with the sighting
system and of course the Aesthetics are
pretty unusual at least by by modern
standards let's have a look
thank you
there's some thought gone into
functionality here for that belt of
purple space laser ammo in that there's
a huge long
mg42-esque big long top cover opens up
to flick your belt across and and load
the thing that's cool except that the
trend is pretty Clearly Now towards very
short top covers because what people
want is a stable mounting platform for
optical sights
don't want to have to design a super
tight lock-up for a big long top cover
that makes sense so we have energy
rounds that have some sort of metal
casing that is not being ejected from
the gun there's no way for it to be
ejected so it's all going down range
some point I guess the the casing acts
like a Sabo or something or maybe maybe
it stays with the energy around all the
way down it's just a form of caseless
ammo with a sort of energy payload it's
a semi-hybrid of what we have now or
maybe something like case telescoped
ammunition or caseless telescope
ammunition it's it's meant to evoke the
the belt fed machine gun but with
purple space lasers
a very cool edgy name for this one and
it's uh it's a Bullpup so I
automatically like it and a very firearm
design so it's it's uh not I presume not
an energy weapon can't see any well the
the significant design cue is probably
the Cutlass style trigger guard which is
probably from the Tavor and maybe the
blocky front end with the barrel
protruding is a nod to the x95 Tovar I
think I'm reaching there it's a slick
little design the obvious drawback would
be the short length of pull so the
distance between the grip and the and
the butt plate there is super short it's
not ideal for a conventional firearm in
terms of managing recoil or in terms of
cramped ergonomics you would want if
this was real you would want a VHS 2
style adjustable butt plate on the back
the more you look at these things the
more you can see design cues from real
guns but your great risk of reaching
because this is so far removed
[Applause]
all right seeing this in action it's
more clear now to me that this is in
fact a DMR semi-automatic or if you must
battle rifle and I'm slightly allergic
to that so probably could have spotted
that from the shed depth of the magazine
which is which is quite reminiscent of
various
um 7.62 by 51. magazines the magazine
has a what looks like a paddle release
at the front that doesn't make a huge
amount of sense was that a sling swivel
if it's a sling swivel it makes even
less sense I'm just going with what I
can see at the moment but there's no
obvious magazine release that's being
used it's almost like it's got an
automatic eject system for the magazine
but there could be a catch that I'm
missing somewhere
okay guys those were more guns from
Destiny 2. I know we have some big
Destiny fans out there that are waiting
for more of these so I hope you enjoyed
those thanks very much for joining us
check out our Royal armories social
media channels our own YouTube channel
if you'd like to as well otherwise we
will see you again here on gaming spot
next week